the ancient Greeks told of how
Prometheus stole fire from the gods and
brought it to humankind
today prometheus is bringing better
observability to cover nannies operators
as a leading open-source monitoring
framework in this episode we'll look at
how to set up Prometheus on ggae and use
it to instrument your application with
custom metrics this is the stack doctor
[Music]
last time we looked at how to use open
census to add custom metrics to our
application today we'll do the same with
Prometheus before we start a bit of
background prometheus is an open source
systems monitoring and alerting toolkit
originally built at SoundCloud it has a
very active developer and user community
and join the cloud native computing
foundation in 2016 so how do you set it
up the fastest and easiest way to
actually set up for me theist and your
gke cluster is to use helm which is a
package manager for kubernetes once you
have helm installed and configured you
can install Prometheus in your cluster
simply by running the helm install
stable slash Prometheus command the
install will create multiple components
the Prometheus server itself and export
are running on every node to capture
node statistics alert manager to send
email notifications and the push gateway
to accept metrics to be pushed to
Prometheus will primarily interact with
the server let's validate the
installation by port forwarding the
server pod to our localhost this allows
us to access the Prometheus UI and graph
metrics to confirm that data collection
and persistence are working now that
Prometheus is installed we are ready to
start adding metric instrumentation to
our application but first let's quickly
review the kinds of metrics that
Prometheus supports a counter is a
cumulative metric that represents a
single increasing value that can only
increase or be reset to zero and restart
for example you can use a counter to
represent a number of requests served
tasks completed or errors a gage is a
metric that represents a single
numerical value that can arbitrarily go
up and down gages are typically used for
measured values like temperatures or
current memory usage but also counts
like the number of concurrent requests a
histogram samples observation
and counts them in configurable buckets
it also provides a sum of all observed
values histograms are most often used to
measure the distributions of things like
request durations or response sizes
finally a summary samples observations
and provides a total count and a sum of
all observed values it also calculates
configurable quantiles over a sliding
time window summaries are usually used
to values where the total value is
important like payload sizes now that we
know what kind of metrics we can expose
in our application it's important to
understand how Prometheus itself works
it's a basic pull model our application
needs to expose a dedicated end point
where the metrics will be available and
we'll need to tell Prometheus where that
end point is and how frequently
described for metrics let's do both of
those now first let's instrument our
application we'll create a simple go
application expose a gauge metric in it
here's the code you can find a link to
the repo in the video description the
first step is to define the metric
itself as a gauge and provide its name
in a description next we create a
function that will set the value of our
metric in our example we're just
generating a random value so that we
know it'll change every time now we can
run our application when we access the
metrics endpoint we can see that our
custom metric is generated and shown
here now our application is instrumented
with a custom metric which is being
exported to Prometheus we need to tell
Prometheus where to find this
information we'll do that by adding some
annotations in the deployment spec in
our application before we deploy to
kubernetes will enable scraping and
define the port an end point where the
metrics are available our last step is
to set up stackdriver integration to
have this metric being just a tin to
stack driver will install the stack
driver collector on our cluster which
will patch the Prometheus server
deployment now when we go to metrics
Explorer we can see our random value
metric there I hope that you've seen how
Prometheus is a fantastic way to add
custom metric instrumentation to your
application and have those metrics being
just an intact driver thank you for
joining me today and come back next time
when we explore options for managing
monitoring and logging costs that's it
for this episode this is the stack
doctor stay healthy out there
[Music]
you
[Music]